il y a un quiz qui a été fait
spécialement euh sur Déclic Théâtre
alors moi je ne sais rien de ce quiz
mais comme d'habitude mais c'est Nicolas
dandry qui vient avec Grégory canalet
bonsoir qui a préparé ce Queen
c'est cette tenue n'est-ce pas
différent
je peux vous le dire
des ardoises de jeux donc que je vous
explique un peu les règles pour ce quiz
spécial attendez je vous la porte
Grégory donc d'un côté nous avons
L'Équipe TV 78
non pas de cri de guerre
d'accord
donc nous sommes sur un match déclicate
vous êtes la présentatrice vous êtes
tout de suite
le règlement les questions vont être
posées vont s'afficher vous aurez le
temps d'écrire la réponse sur votre
ardoise vous attendez dès que je vous
dis vous montrez vos réponses et donc ce
n'est pas un quiz de rapidité c'est bien
un quiz et bien il peut y avoir égalité
à la fin voilà si vous trichez
les cartons rouges alors je sais que ça
c'est finalement ce sont les fiches pour
voter c'est ça c'est le public
habituellement moi je m'en sers de
carton rouge ce soir si il y a des
tricheurs j'enlève des points voilà
alors on va commencer avec la première
question c'est parti donc l'idée en fait
c'est de savoir quand est-ce qu'a été
créé enfin pardon où a été créé le le
théâtre d'improvisation
[Musique]
Québec
Canada c'est bien vous écoutez bien vos
invités
pour tout le monde on va voir la réponse
s'afficher
0,5 bonus alors donc en fait
effectivement ça a été créé au Québec en
1977 exactement voilà par deux comédiens
qui s'appelle Robert Gravel et Yvon
leducs
un pour Télé 78 2 pour déconnecter
on va voir à la fin allez deuxième
question je vous propose de regarder cet
extrait qui date de 2003 nous sommes en
plein match d'improvisation entre les
juniors de trappes et de plaisir à la
Maurice regardez motivation mixte
qui aura pour thème
Argar
nombre de joueurs un par équipe ambiance
électrique à la Merise ce mardi pour le
gala d'ouverture de la quatrième édition
des vacances de l'impro à Trappes sur la
patinoire les équipes junior d'un pro de
trappes et plaisir dans les tribunes les
jeunes susceptibles de suivre les
ateliers d'un pro l'enjeu de cette
rencontre s'amusait certes mais aussi
donner un aperçu de l'improvisation
théâtrale la question qui suis-je le nom
exact s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
qui est-ce qu'on voit à l'écran là c'est
ça qui est ce monsieur qui suis-je et je
peux vous dire qu'il y a des dossiers si
vous regardez les images il y a des
dossiers sociaux
voilà des dossiers ce soir sur tv78
réutilisables évidemment pour les
prochains matchs alors les réponses
pardon pour l'écriture j'écris très
bonne nouvelle
réponse pour TV 78 et bonne réponse pour
l'équipe Déclic Théâtre donc on a les
devoir aller chercher Janane bodili qui
est toute jeune sur cette image Janane
qui a été chroniqueuse télé en fait
c'est pour ça j'ai cru que vous allez
vous demander ça
les questions qui est compliqué
historique de Déclic Théâtre il a
commencé l'impro en troisième après une
rencontre avec Alain de bois alias papi
allez troisième question un nouvel
extrait nous sommes en 2004 les cadets
les juniors de Déclic Théâtre sont
invités au Festival dans les nuages un
événement organisé par l'association
nuage France pour valoriser le travail
artistique des jeunes et des
associations dans les quartiers regardez
cette extrait bon je le comprends
capitaine si tu si nous sommes au
premier étage c'est déjà impressionnant
vous êtes pas au deuxième encore hein
[Musique]
la semaine dernière
question très compliquée je vous
l'accorde et où est-ce que ça se déroule
en fait
où est-ce que ça se déroule on a bien
écouté papier au début l'arbitre il y a
un indice et c'est dans un monument
on va regarder les réponses
s'il vous plaît
château de Versailles première étage
Tour Eiffel Paris
se situe papa
c'est un monument écoutez on va écouter
cet extrait
de venir ça m'a quand même fait plaisir
de venir faire un match d'impôts au
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
bonne réponse de Déclic Théâtre donc
nous sommes à Paris
quatrième question direction le théâtre
des blancs manteau à Paris nous sommes
en 2005 et je vous propose de regarder
ce spectacle avec des comédiens
historiques de Déclic Théâtre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous entendez les enfants il y a des
salles comme ça qui véhiculent qui
véhicule tout un passé à artistique
sympa et puis comme comme je fais
également du café théâtre pour moi ça a
toujours une signification assez
assez forte de jouer au blanc
[Musique]
c'est un humoriste
s'il vous plaît
Mathilde Franco le but n'est pas de
recopier des questions s'il vous plaît
et donc oui oui c'est ça il s'agit bien
de Arnaud de Arnaud de sa mère pardon
Arnaud de sa mère avec la petite porte
Arnaud de sa mère Arnaud de sa mère
originaire de 50 ans divine qui a
commencé donc à décrire voilà allez
regardez ces images une finale d'un
match j'impro dans les années 90 d'un
côté vous avez les rouges et noir ce
sont les noflats dans les baptisé comme
ça de l'autre les noirs et blanc ce sont
les facultron on est dans les années 90
on allait chercher très loin sur TV 78
c'était un derby à l'époque les naufar
Passos facult trou pardon et alors qui
sont-ils en fait c'est qui les naufleurs
c'est qui les facultés
[Musique]
c'est de l'histoire là on est vraiment
dans l'histoire de décrypter d'ailleurs
puisque c'est des thématiques cette
année pour le Championnat du Monde moi
j'ai choisi à la manière de Pierre
Perret parce que ce soir vous saurez
tout tout sur et bien déclicitez
j'en ai qu'un sur les deux ah bah oui
donc c'était l'équipe en fait et bien de
Déclic Théâtre vendredi mais nous plats
de trappes et donc on va voir tout de
suite l'extrait pour voir la réponse
vendredi 27 juin ce jouet la grande
finale du City le championnat
départemental d'improvisation théâtrale
des Yvelines c'est à l'espace Coluche de
plaisir que devait se dérouler cette
finale derby qui opposait les noflards
de Trappes ou facultron de l'Université
de Saint-Quentin une soirée mouvementée
en perspective avec deux équipes qui se
connaissent bien allez cinquième
question retour en 2001 lors de la
finale des championnats de France junior
des matchs d'impro regardez cet extrait
champion de France
sinon
l'équipe de frappe de l'impro c'est bien
construite ici et elle se développe
beaucoup à Trappes et je pense que
bientôt tout le monde va vous le Renfer
quoi dans
l'Europe
j'ai rien compris
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est deux personnes nous
font beaucoup rire donc quels sont les
deux personnes que vous venez voir qui
sont bien connues aujourd'hui
une femme
s'il vous plaît autour de la table
voilà
donc
cette tv78 toujours derrière mais
allez-y
victoire il reste une seule question on
arrive à la dernière question une
spéciale alors juste je vais vous dire
la règle de cette qui est pour cette
question vous allez voir plusieurs
personnalités dans l'extrait qui suit en
fait on mettra une enchère combien de
personnalités vous êtes capable de me
donner donc vous notez pas encore mais
vous allez me donner on va voir
l'extrait
tout de suite on regarde le Bataclan à
Paris a été pris d'assaut hier soir pour
la soirée exceptionnelle en faveur du
projet de la marmite imaginé par
l'association basée à Élancourt Jamel
Debbouze toujours fidèle à ses racines a
suédérer autour de lui des artistes
comiques du moment des copains venus
gracieusement par solidarité envers un
projet culturel qui devrait notamment
permettre à la compagnie de recentrer
toutes ses activités en un seul lieu à
Trappes et d'accroître les formations
d'improvisation le public composé en
grande partie du jeûne venus de 50 ans
mais aussi de toute la région parisienne
n'a pas hésité à suivre Jamel pour aider
Déclic Théâtre bilan de l'opération près
de 200000 francs récoltés pour la
marmite il y a une vraie intention
heureuse de faire rire tous les gens
sont venus pour ça et on s'est bien
marré et en plus il y avait espèce
d'émotion de solidarité c'est bien c'est
toujours bien ça c'est un pote puis en
écrit ensemble un scénario donc je vais
le voir je connais la plupart des gens
qui étaient là je les aime bien je suis
venu avec plaisir voir ces gens-là
alors combien de personnalités êtes-vous
capable de me donner 10
il y a un moment je m'y connais pas trop
quoi
deux points pour déclic puisque c'est
une question spéciale alors Jamel
Debbouze Alain Degois
Eric et Ramzy est-ce que ça fait deux
Eric et Jean-Pierre Bacri oui Jean-Paul
Rouve oui
Dieudonné oui
Pierre Palmade
on va voir tout de suite la réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
mais Grégory vous avez triché en fait
vous connaissez déjà toutes les
questions
il me semble qu'il y a égalité bah du
coup on a égalisé ouais vous avez
égalisé
du coup j'avais une dernière question
puisque on vient de jouer à ce jeu avec
vous sur déclicate déclicate ça
représente quoi pour vous peut-être
Grégory canalet qui est qui avait très
bien répondu à beaucoup de questions ça
représente quoi pour vous décrypter pour
moi c'est indissociable de Trappes voilà
l'identité de trap et après bah c'est
des noms on les a vu s'afficher le
premier nom qui vient forcément à
l'esprit c'est Jamel Debbouze et l'autre
mot bien sûr c'est improvisation moi
c'est les premiers mots qui me qui me
viennent à l'esprit Gabriel je suis
assez d'accord avec Grégory je pense que
c'est quand même un emblème dans les
Yvelines avec beaucoup de talents qui
ont émergé donc
Amel pour moi c'est moi j'ai envie de
dire coeur parce que c'est ma c'est ma
compagnie de coeur c'est ma deuxième
famille des petits théâtres j'y
travaille depuis maintenant quelques
années vu que je suis j'y suis entrée en
2010 et c'est aussi encore beaucoup de
partages puisque je rencontre des
nouvelles personnalités ces jeunes
improvisateurs qui qui sont déjà
aujourd'hui capables de mettre une jolie
fessée dans la patinoire donc donc voilà
j'ai hâte de partager d'autres moments
avec eux Baptiste
mais oui c'est ça c'est une deuxième
famille c'est je sais que les personnes
que j'ai rencontré
grâce à des filles théâtre à mon avis il
y en a plein que je l'aurais jamais
rencontré dans la vie de tous les jours
et qui aujourd'hui sont font partie de
mes amis donc et qui je pense le
resteront tout le temps
une phrase à l'impro que
à la pratique dans une patinoire on va
rencontrer nos meilleures amies et je
trouve que cette phrase est très vraie
parce que aujourd'hui mes meilleurs amis
avec qui je passe tous mes moments c'est
des personnes qui j'ai rencontrées
grâce à des clips théâtre et grâce à
l'impro du coup ouais je dirais famille
Grégory
hier un atelier il y aura un reportage
qui va paraître un peu plus tard j'en
profite pour faire ma propre pub et moi
c'est vrai ce que j'ai senti dans
l'atelier c'est une grande cohésion il y
a le mot famille qui est revenu entre
vous il y a quand même une cohésion on
la sent ça se ressent en tout cas de vu
de l'extérieur ouais c'est pas c'est
vraiment après c'est pour ça ça c'est le
principe aussi du des ateliers c'est de
créer une cohésion parce que bah tous
les ans il y en a qui sortent il y en a
d'autres qui arrivent dans un nouveau
groupe du coup le but c'est aussi
d'essayer de désintégrer au plus vite
par exemple mon cas est arrivé cette
année avec nous
et j'ai l'impression qu'on l'a bien
accueilli quand même
une notion de nous
on est
on se sent un peu
mal très très fort en fait ce qu'on
partage on part pas on partage pas juste
des moments de spectacle on a enfin
c'est ouais c'est très fort et bravo
déclité pour ça et bien merci à vous
pour ces mots touchants la famille on
sent l'émotion merci d'être venu et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions